[Musique]
comme tous les ans le conseil
départemental de la Réunion a convié la
communauté musulmane de Lille a célébré
l'Aïd oulfitr qui marque la fin du mois
sacré du Ramadan une cérémonie qui s'est
déroulée ce mercredi 24 mai au jardin de
l'État décoré aux couleurs de l'Orient
pour l'occasion accueilli par des chants
traditionnellementhorés le président du
Département Cyril Melchior et ses
conseillers départementaux accompagnés
par Nazir Patel président du conseil
régional du culte musulman et Frédéric
maillot conseiller régional se sont
ensuite attardés sur les différents
ateliers mettant à l'honneur les arts et
savoir-faire du monde musulman la fête
de l'Aïd est un grand moment pour
l'ensemble de la communauté réunionnaise
parce que nous sommes
multiculturels
multicultuel et bien nous devons
partager ce moment c'est ce que fait le
département à travers donc cette belle
fête ici dans le jardin de pour dire que
nous portons un message d'espoir à
travers la célébration de la fête de
l'Aïd c'est le message d'espoir c'est de
protéger de préserver notre bien vivre
ensemble et pour le faire et bien
célébrer toutes les fêtes et en
particulier ben la fête de l'Aïd avec
tous nos amis de professions musulmane
tous nos frères et soeurs de confessions
musulmane bonne fête à toutes une soirée
qui sait poursuivie avec des animations
chant défilé de tenue traditionnelle ou
encore danse orientale le département
rassemble et c'est un moment
extraordinairement convivial ou
l'ensemble de la composante musulmane se
retrouve avec des élus avec nos
représentants pour partager ce moment
d'amitié et convivialité de fraternité
alors moi je remercie énormément le
président Cyril mercure mais également
toute son équipe qui ont travaillé
sûrement d'arrache-pied pour mettre en
place toute cette super be organisation
ce soir pour nous accueillir dans des
conditions optimales confortables avec
un programme de très grande qualité un
moment de convivialité et de partage qui
témoignent une fois de plus du vivre
ensemble réunionnais
[Musique]